Florida teenagers home this morning
after running away with a high school
soccer coach for nearly a week 17 year
old Katelyn for Xena was reunited with
her mom and dad over the weekend in
Syracuse New York the 20s 27 year old
Ryan Rodriguez is now under arrest
Meg Oliver spoke with frizziness parents
after the reunion and an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning that
we are all so glad that she is home safe
absolutely good morning to all of you
these last few days have been an
emotional roller coaster for the prasena
family they say they're happy to have
their daughter back and safe in their
arms and that rodriguez will face
consequences for taking the child away
when you saw her for the first time what
was that like for you Ward I like the
weight of the world on my shoulders
diving Ward frisina initially blamed
himself for his daughter's disappearance
he encouraged 27 year old Ryan Rodriguez
to apply for the high school coaching
job that brought him into their lives
Ward how are you holding up it's been
difficult I'm glad to have my daughter
back where I know I can protect her and
keep her safe as a father always wants
to do Ward and Scarlett frisina traveled
more than a thousand miles to reunite
with their daughter in New York how long
did you hug her - we had to breathe I
think when you go that long without
seeing we're talking to her
you don't wanna let her go police say a
New York state trooper noticed
Rodriguez's car with the florida tag the
officer pulled him over in a shopping
mall parking lot and arrested him
without incident frissina was in the
passenger seat did she tell you why she
left we haven't gotten into all of that
yet and we will at some point right now
we're just so thankful and so blessed
that she's safe and that we're together
again according to the arrest warrant
the teens father discovered sexual
messages from snapchat after she
disappeared that confirmed a possible
relationship between his daughter and
Rodriguez and her mother was told by one
of Kaitlyn's friends that Ryan wanted
Caitlyn to leave the country with him
and she didn't know how to get out of it
and was afraid he
mess up her life what's the message you
want to send out to other parents after
going through this week because you
don't know what tomorrow brings is to
hug your babies every day and tell them
how much you love them and make sure
that they know that they can come to you
with anything and that year you can work
through whatever it is rodriguez faces a
felony charge in Florida of interfering
with child custody and he could face
additional federal charges for taking
frisina across state lines officials say
if there are no local charges filed in
New York they expect Rodriguez to be
extradited to Florida this week as you
can imagine this family has a lot to
process I think the mom said a very good
thing when she said tell your kids no
matter what it is you can talk to us
about it because my heart ached for her
when I saw on TV pleading with her
daughter please just call us and let let
us know you're all right
that's the message they're gonna take
this day by day but they're even gonna
go to counseling if they have to go
through this did she go with him
willingly it seems as if she did they
didn't know that he had a relationship
until after they disappeared thank
goodness a friend came forward and oh
this could have ended a lot worse yeah
we're fortunate for them Meg thank you
sir